mais beaucoup de marques comme sa
josiane 1 à st dervin la langue cgc
parce que tu trouves comment roger pro
vie à cause de ma grosse bouse jédir je
viens c'est parce que je suis pas
sensible aux magasins easy ii actuel
marceau forcé sur leurs roses
seulement je raconterai site avec une
guerre juste bien je préfère que tu me
disais mon camarade ce coma je dérange
j'ai horreur de la vulgarité et pique à
socialement et des pickups moment je
vais défiler mon fiancé un bon
divertissement mobile ça ma porte à clé
des scones à présente à toquer à la
porte
c'est mince pies ces personnes même si
l'année suivante et c'était peut-être ma
fiancée bourbier son parapluie quelques
cieux et si je veux pas le sais pas
qu'est ce qui me retient comme un jardin
comme qu'elle n'a peut être pas de
préjudice masse de dépression finma des
secondes après kata bien josiane junte
un barouf junte en ont parlé que c'est
un genre de meurtrier jeudi main sais
pas mais qu'est ce que je vais devenir
je suis toute seule dans ma petite fille
heureusement ça longtemps que je
travaille comme dame au chapeau ne sais
pas si je vais rester parce que j'ai à
dire une chose n'a pas tendu par un
quatrième en ruine l'activité de la
compromission alors saisi d'une demande
de levée d'ivoire un g2 lac l'accord de
pas grand chose maintenant pour appeler
de l'autre avaient saisi un presse
papier j'ai passé une année blanche
jusqu'à 7 heures sur mon lit tu vas
comme suppléant alors que j'arrive aux
allocations la patronne et si vous
n'avez pas à côté de sa cliente
en gt1 bull j'ai dit je m'énerve
vraiment c'est pas possible je dis mais
enfin j'ai envie d'arrêter de faire mon
travail c'est un brushing aux posters ou
l'or tu fermes ta lumière devient ma
barbe y est c'est vrai c'est parce qu'il
a vécu mince
j'ai toujours aussi moi j'ai pas ça ne
passera pas j'ai entendu dire qu'il y
avait déjà dit qu écrivent aux vedettes
alors je lui s'il vous quoi décrète pas
c'est vrai quoi j'ai pas pu masquer une
note
j'ai fait une lettre tu puisses te dit
que j'ai et demi ça veut dire jamais
retient pas pipi un jeu fait drôlement
bien
j'ai pas payer cher tintin monoprix
attend qu est ce que j ai ni que j'aime
me dit non c'est pas moi c'est la
meilleure de l'année
je sais pas si c'est la chaleur ou quoi
mais je suis complètement pété un plomb
à oui si puissamment vient de kazan
avait ému pour commencer non j'ai dit je
t'aime mon génie je te veux je sais ce
qu'elle a mises oscillent entre
parenthèses jonnhy ton sexe judiciaire
c'est par an savait mais seulement je te
veux c'est quand même de réserver si
jenny comme tu es beau tu vas qui dépote
ce travail au pôle du mois ces cinq ans
quitte à chine je ne contrôle plus
j'aime y aussi ta liberté c'est mon
bonheur ça c'est beau comme formellement
je vais tomber comme ça j'ai réfléchi je
suis une pac ne sera pas que c'est toute
façon pourquoi que je fais rangez les
dans la passe comment fait on s'est dit
que ça pue tellement charme